i was raised on a farm with my  grandmother  um  for the first six years of my life i  knew somehow that my life would be  different and it would be better i never  had a clear  cut vision of what it was i would be  doing i just always felt somehow i  remember  absolutely physically feeling it at  around four years old i remember  standing  on the back porch it was a screened-in  porch and my grandmother was boiling  clothes because you know during the at  that time we didn't have washing  machines until people would you know  physically  boil clothes in a great big iron pot and  she was boiling clothes and poking them  down and i was watching her from the  back porch and i was four years old and  i remember thinking my life won't be  like this  my life won't be like this it will be  better and it wasn't uh from a place of  arrogance it was just  a place of knowing that things could be  different from me somehow i don't know  what made me think that